Atropa belladonna will kill you datura
will put you to sleep forever
akan item will kill you Lala will
produce cyanide and kill you
every plant team in the poison garden is
poisonous and has the ability to kill
you my name's Trevor Jones and I'm the
head gardener of Annika garden
this plant is giant hogweed it will get
up to around about 8 foot high
it's photo toxic so will burn your skin
and give you blisters for up to 7 years
this garden is set in the wall garden of
the old castle in Northumberland Newgate
would have learned about 95 plants and
we're adding to the collection of all
time this plant is a key item or
monkshood wonderful blue flowers but the
whole of the plant is poisonous the
berries crushed up and fed to you will
kill you the leaves themselves will kill
you also
as will the root and the stem we have
told you maintain the garden so we have
to tend the plants and when we do that
we have to be very careful of the way we
operate so we have to cover some of our
skin when we deal with particularly
dangerous plants this plant is log it
produces cyanide and we all know what
that will do to you so it's the
brainchild of the Duchess Duchess of
Northumberland so rather than having a
herb garden she decided to create more
interest and have a poison garden
they're very very common plants in fact
a lot of them like what we call cottage
garden plants and they're grown in many
people's gardens but people don't know
how far four they actually are
this is Atropa belladonna four berries
are enough to kill a child
people have intrigued by poisonous
plants and often very worried when they
come out because many of them will be
growing these plants at home they don't
realize that powerful impact plants can
have on us as humans definitely it's a
good way to get rid of your life